[Music]
is that them or us that's you i thought
does it sound like god like you yeah the
sanderson sisters are resurrecting again
bette midler sarah jessica parker and
kathy and the jimmy react to the latest
hocus pocus 2 trailers
[Applause]
that looks fabulous
some legends never die i love that wow
wow and we love that these three legends
are together again the trio are
reuniting for the highly anticipated
sequel to disney's 1993 hocus pocus
the witches are back september 30th on
disney plus for you guessed it
the sequel is set 29 years after the
first film
i'm incredibly excited the sisters
return after high school friends
reignite the black flame candle safe to
say that thackery binks would be totally
disappointed
do the honors no thanks
stupid cat now it's up to a new group to
stop the salem witches once and for all
last year kathy who plays mary sanderson
recalled an epic fan girl moment to e.t
before working with bette midler as her
co-star oh boy we've only really had one
day of shooting they've been shooting
before we got here but we've only had
one day of shooting but you know it's
just great to be back i when i was
growing up my the idol of my life was
brett midler and i used to break into
back stages of where she was performing
i had guards chasing after me true story
found her apartment in new york left her
a note got drug away from there so to be
standing next to her not only in the
same movie of playing her sister
blew my
mind and joining the cast is veep actor
sam richardson who revealed what it's
like working alongside the iconic cast
truly i i'm an absolute
super fan of the original you watch oh
always
grew up watching that movie so to be in
it is so surreal and incredible and then
to work with the ladies
is so
i i i don't use words real again but
like i i'm outside of myself when i'm
doing these scenes i'm like this is them
this is and they're the characters this
is this is oh the sanderson sisters you
know looks like we'll just have to wait
for bet sarah and kathy to
put a spell on us when the movie streams
this fall
i put a spell on you
and now you're my